Drive by day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
All Day.
Okay.
Now what's the situation with Cyborg at this point?
That shit pissed hot again,
waiting for the,
to see what the commission does,
what kind of suspension she's getting at least a year.
At least.
What she pissed hot four is also a,
an anti androgen.
It's a Dyo has DHT inhibitor.
I used to rub that shit in my head to prevent a hair loss.
They might give her three h t and it's also used by people who take steroids to
uh,
diminish the effects of,
um,
of like when females take steroids,
diminish the effect.
It's also a,
it's a masking agent,
so if you've take steroids,
some people take that stuff as a masking Asian,
she's 31.
It's also a diuretic.
So it's a very weird drug called Spiro.
No lack.
Dane lack dean lactone.
But it has many different uses.
If she,
if she gets three years,
that's what's an argument that not a good argument.
All the arguments that she gave her,
not good arguments,
that she took something out of competition that she was told by her doctor that
it'd be okay.
When it's clearly on the Usada banned,
blessed,
it's 100% band.
It's not like there's certain things you could take out us out of context,
like the big ones pot.
Like say if they catch you tomorrow and you're supposed to fight in six months
and you're smoking weed like crazy and they test you and they go,
look,
we got test to go,
I just wanna let you know I've been smoking a lot of weed.
They're like,
okay,
as long as it's not steroids.
That's why John Jones didn't get in trouble when he pissed hot for cocaine three
weeks out of the fight with Daniel Cormier because that's not in competition and
it's not a performance enhancing drug.
He's just partying.
Right?
So what this is though is a performance enhancing drug,
not just a performance enhancing drug,
but problematic in that it inhibits its performance enhancing in that it works
as a diuretic.
You're not allowed to use diuretics,
but it's,
it also inhibits your,
um,
the,
their ability to detect steroids in you.
She's in trouble.
She doesn't show you saw it as going to eat her ass up.
And if she gets three years,
well,
here's the thing,
how old is she?
She's in her mid thirties.
They,
they,
it's time to get tested her because she passed on three world title fights.
They had three world title fights lined up for her at one 45,
which is the weight class that she asked for that she said she couldn't make it
in eight weeks.
And so then they gave her more weeks and they gave her,
yeah,
they gave her a third test and they're like [inaudible] up and whether or not
they were going to test her anyway,
who knows?
But that's when they tested her and that's when she pissed hot.
It makes sense.
And she did not reveal before that,
that she was taking that and then she does the whole thing is she's in trouble.
Have you seen a skip in all babies?
Huge.
This is a skeptical baby now.
Somebody.
Somebody that everybody.
Yeah,
Ken's Kobe ugly that look at this baby.
That's so funny.
It's like bitch,
that's skeptical snakes.
So skeptical with with Cyborg super schedules.
Have you seen the skeptical house?
The motherfucker,
so skeptical.
Skeptical Cadillac,
Cadillac House.
What the fuck?
Is that a real house?
Yes.
Those were windows,
but the fucking window is that skeptical window.
Do you think they did that on purpose?
Hell,
what's wrong with people?
It almost seems like that was an accident.
It's so funny.
Go with Cyborg.
She gets three years.
She's in trouble.
I financially too.
When Rhonda loss again and she's throwing shade at Rhonda,
my bitch,
you,
you need,
you just got busted for steroids.
Shameless or steroids.
She got busted for a dihydrotestosterone.
No,
no,
no.
It's not a precursor.
It's a dihydrotestosterone inhibitor.
That's what it is.
Inhibitor.
Yeah,
and to me,
my brain goes,
you're in trouble.
You're in trouble.
She certainly could be in trouble.
It's one thing if she got,
she said it was,
she's got a bunch of issues because she really did record body getting down to
one 40 which downtime,
which I'm sure that that seems fine when you wreck your body,
like I think she's saying that she takes in too much water now and her body is
like trying to hold on to water and that they gave her a drug to diminish the
amount of water.
I talked to a couple of doctors about this.
I asked some questions and they all gave me that snake face generally
in there,
you know her background too.
It's like,
fuck man,
he don't fuck with anything that's illegal and you definitely don't fuck with
anything that people use because they're women that take steroids.
Even if it's just a coincidence that you happened to be,
you should look at every fucking label extremely carefully.
Is that the worst cut of all time?
Yeah,
it's one of them.
What do you mean cut?
But here's the thing,
man,
thought of all chis Diego Sanchez made one 45 be fought and won 85 and ultimate
fighter one Kenny Floyd.
Here's the problem.
She fucking dead lifts 305 pounds a couple weeks after passing on fights,
she passes on the fight and then puts up Instagrams of her dead lifting massive
weight.
You're in,
you know,
and it was whoever the fuck handles her Twitter account because I wrote that up
because a I,
me and Brett Akimoto,
we're having a discussion about it on Twitter.
Very good dude.
We were having a little back and forth on Twitter about it and uh,
you know,
he said,
doesn't it weird that she's not fighting for the title?
And I'm like,
what's weird is that they pack that she passed on title fight and then post
Instagram photos of her dead lifting and then she responded that it's just like
what football players do when they're not in camp.
And I'm like,
what?
You saw that,
that golden snitch was like,
what?
What'd you say song?
He,
she's not writing now I'm looking at the English is perfect.
I'm like,
this is not,
this is whoever works with her or her boyfriend or whoever the fuck handles the,
the Instagram account.
I'm like,
that's no excuse.
There's a lot of maintenance that you do that's not dead lifting.
305 fucking pounds.
You do that to put on mass.
That is why you dead lift you dead lift to put fucking mass.
She's got Muto mass.
He's got plenty of mass.
She has no problem with mass,
you know?
I mean,
that's not what she needs.
If she really wants a fight at 145 pounds and she needs more than eight weeks to
make the weight,
what she should be doing is longterm cardio.
I guess that's what she's doing too though,
Jo.
She goes,
I do that and then the morning I run every morning though.
Dude,
come the fuck on.
Those are,
those aren't as heavy as they learn to develop that power son.
No,
no,
no.
That's 300 some pounds.
That's 305 pounds,
bro.
That's what she's doing.
This is youtube though.
Why did she tag?
Why did she take Gabby Garcia?
That's worse.
Get here we go see a help tab.
You just started curling that shit.
You have the same doctor.
I Dunno.
Fuck say look,
the whole thing is awful.
It's awful.
I whoever the fuck is he in her corner that let her post that video.
I'd be like,
Hey,
hey,
what are you doing with your phone?
What are you doing with your phone?
You're going to put that online,
get the fuck out.
Give me just the golden snitches and literally just waiting.
Yeah.
If he's talking to a woman,
dead lifting 305 for reps were going there.
6:00 AM tomorrow morning.
Yeah.
Boom.
I mean,
look,
it is possible that you could get that big and that jacked without anything,
but it takes a long fucking time and that's what you're doing.
That's what you're doing all the time.
If you look at some of those crossfit gals that some of those are on steroids,
100% but some of them are not and you can get big if you have the right genetics
and you do that kind of lifting.
Yeah,
but that kind of lifting is for people that want to put on power.
She's got ridiculous power.
Cyborg has some of the nastiest power you're ever going to see in women's MMA
most probably the most.
The most it right up there with,
well,
she has the full range.
Like she'll kick you a knee you and punch you and elbow you where Nunez Nunez
will kick you hard.
But it's her punches that are fucking ferocious and she doesn't hit hard and
sideboard.
No Way.
Sorry.
Subway hits you like Wendy Tyson with braids.
She hits.
Yeah,
she hits girls.
You see the cop?
No fucking kind of shut off the bat.
She makes worldclass girls look like that.
Grandma and my cousin,
she's a beast monster.
Unfortunate that there's so much controversy.
Like I would love if there was someone like cyborg with no shade attached to it,
no weirdness attached to it.
But now she's got these two strikes against her.
Will Amanda Nunez,
she has no shade.
Yes.
She knocks girls out.
She just Merck,
Misha Tate,
eh.
You know,
we can argue probably the number two most famous girl of all time in women's MMA
and it's just Merck.
The number one.
Yeah.
Here's your star with no shade.
Great Person.